là on est en train de préparer le pire
avec des réformes terrible que ce soit
sur l'assurance chômage que ce soit sur
la réforme des retraites et en matière
de santé et mener le maquereau un bilan
catastrophique c'est plus de 5700 lee
qui ont fermé en 2020 au coeur de la
crise qu vide près c'est bon mais s'il
faut pondérer il ya comme des animations
ont été ouverts oui une volonté 35
attendu à 2 sur 10 ans en fait de lits
fermés les ouvrages changer leur système
ambulatoire mais c'est certain que oui
on est en train de déshabiller la france
et peu d'investissements
on est parfaitement d'accord ils ont
tenu à bout de bras l'économie dans
cette dans cette crise voilà et il n'ya
pas y'a pas de penser à long terme c'est
certain et on peut le voir aussi en
matière diplomatique comme avec ces
histoires de sous marins on l'entend pas
macron il n'y a pas de politique
générale on sait pas qui sont les alliés
de la france on sait pas où ça va du
tout je suis parfaitement d'accord mais
aussi on sait il il est totalement
européiste et en ça ils l'appliquent
absolument à la lettre ce qu'on lui
demande de faire il est en train de
vendre à la découpe les bijoux de
famille en france on l'a vu ça a
commencé avec alstom et ça a continué et
ça va me faire qu'empirer